a lot of the ways that people talk about
making a difference are not making a
difference
they just feel good and I think in the
future our children and our
grandchildren or great-grandchildren
aren't gonna look back and say what a
great grandpa band feel now they're
gonna look back and say what a great
grandpa been through
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special we're joined
today by Jonathan Safran Foer he's the
author of among other books everything
is illuminated Extremely Loud and
Incredibly Close and most recently Here
I am and he's here to talk about his
brand-new book which is actually about
climate change we are the weather it's
available on September 17th you can
pre-order it now Jonathan thanks so much
for stopping by I really appreciate it
very happy to be here one of the things
that's interesting about having you on
is obviously my catch phrase is the
whole facts don't care about your
feelings stick but so much of your
writing is deeply felt how do you
balance those elements when you're
talking about public policy issues like
how to deal with the possibility of
future climate change I'll get to that
in just one second but first these days
a lot of workplaces offer employees some
pretty nice perks we have pretty great
perks here at the Daily wire sometimes
we bring in free food sometimes we even
let people go home at night I mean we
have great perks around here one of
those perks at some companies is life
insurance but you don't want to rely on
workplace insurance this is where policy
genius comes in policy genius it's the
easy way to shop for life insurance
online in minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find the right
amount of coverage at the best possible
price the policy genius team can look at
your workplace life insurance policy and
then help you decide what else you might
need and what you actually don't policy
genius doesn't just do life insurance
either they can also help you find the
right home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance so remember
workplace life insurance policies are
like workplace snacks they are better
than nothing but they are not quite
enough head on over to policy genius
calm right now today find out how to
supplement your workplace life insurance
and better protect your family policy
genius it's like a buffet made of life
insurance what could be more delicious
than that what could be more incredible
go be an adult get life insurance policy
genius calm makes it easy okay so how do
you separate out what the thrust of what
you're trying to say is from from the
feelings how much of it is is reasoned
argument and how much of it is just the
the drive toward a moral feeling that
you're going for well to begin with a
little humility I can't I don't know for
sure because feelings are distorting and
oftentimes we don't realize the extent
to which our feelings are distorting our
thoughts and we might think that we're
being clear-headed but we think that
with the head that is clouded right that
slogan though could also have been the
slogan of this book the this like
central premise of we are the weather is
that we are way too engaged with our
feelings and not nearly enough engaged
with the facts or our actions so for
example we've created this all-important
dichotomy between people who are climate
change deniers which to say those who
don't accept that human activity is
changing our environment changing the
climate and people who accept that what
the scientists what 97% of the
scientists seem to agree on and what I
say at the beginning of the book is this
is not the right psychotic to make
because in fact a lot of people who
would consider themselves
environmentalists behave in ways that
are virtually identical to people who
are so-called climate change deniers and
in fact denial comes in a lot of
different forms you know denial can of
course be denial on the basis of
information but can also be a kind of
denial in believing that accepting
knowledge accepting science is virtuous
which it isn't necessarily not in and of
itself if I found out that I had cancer
knowing that I have cancer is going to
do nothing about stopping the spread of
my cancer I have to seek the advice of
people who know more than me hopefully
get multiple opinions and then take an
action that however uncertain it might
be seems to be the most thoughtful and
careful action so this is not a lot of
books about the environment I've read a
fair number of books as I'm sure you
have as well an awful lot of them move
me for 15 pages 20 pages like most
people I can get very swayed by these
sort of doomsday predictions without
either questioning the validity of them
or questioning what they have to do with
me you know as if learning about these
potential outcomes somehow was a way in
participating in the avoidance of them
which it isn't so when I wrote this book
I wanted to actually move beyond
feelings and to be very careful about
you know what is it that as an
individual I'm not a legislator and I'm
not a particularly political person
I am a dad I'm a New Yorker I'm a Jewish
person as we just said and I'm a citizen
of both America and the world what can I
do in the confines of my home and with
the voice that I have to make a
difference and so that was what I
started to research and what I found was
a lot of the ways that people talk about
making a difference are not making a
difference
they just feel good and I think in the
future our children and our
grandchildren or great-grandchildren
aren't gonna look back and say what did
great-grandpa Ben feel you know they're
gonna look back and say what a great
grandpa Ben do well that is a really
interesting question because you're
right that there has been the sort of
weird political dichotomy over climate
change denial ISM and one of my big
Bugaboos has been the idea that if I
disagree with somebody on policy but I
fully accept the IPCC estimates about
the range of possibilities inherent in
climate change if I if I accept that
sometime between now and the end of the
century there will be a change in the
climate that is largely related to human
activity somewhere between two degrees
Celsius and six degrees Celsius but I
also disagree with a particular policy
this makes me a denier it seems like
that is a form of virtue signaling that
is unjustified by the fact and this does
bring us to sort of the central
contention of your book your book is
really based on what you say is
individual activity but I wonder if
there are environmentalists we're gonna
criticize the book by pointing out that
in the end this is really a collective
solution that's necessary so you know we
can dig all the wells that we want and
build all the solar panels on our houses
that we want and we can do like Prince
Charles and Prince William and talk
about not having as many kids but in the
end if half the globe besides not to
participate none of this is gonna make
any difference at all so you talked a
lot about what individuals can do how do
you deal with the criticism that and the
focus on the individual is actually
wrongheaded that if you don't have
government's cooperating on some sort of
global solution that in essence the
free-rider problem destroys any
possibility of change in the first place
well first of all I would say your
description of climate change is exactly
right and it's admirable and it's worth
acknowledging that there is a broad
consensus that not only a scientific
consensus but a popular consensus not
only among Democrats but among
Republicans
as well that what as to what you just
said that we are on this path the
temperatures are increasing because of
human activity you even were bold enough
to like put put numbers on it which are
the numbers I would put on it and are
the numbers that frankly 97% of
scientists would put on it so we don't
disagree about the science and that's a
huge step forward now the goal posts
have really been moving in terms of the
different kinds of denial it used to be
the case that there was a fairly large
swath of the population that said it's
just not happening and then it was it's
happening but it's not happening because
of human activity then it was it is
happening because of human activity but
it's not that bad and now I think we're
in a place where we say this could be
bad we don't know exactly how bad but it
could be bad and so let's be thoughtful
about it and I would have a hard time
respecting somebody who said this isn't
happening in much the same way that I
would have a hard time respecting
somebody who believed in Bigfoot but if
somebody says I am with you on the on
the basic science and the ideas I have
it I have a different notion of how we
should address that I have nothing but
respect for that and I might try to have
a conversation where I share my
perspective and hopefully in a way that
isn't binary like it's it's not as if we
do it my way or we do it your way
it may be that they at the end of this
conversation you say you know I'm sort
of compelled what you had to say about
diet I'm not gonna become a vegan I'm
not gonna become a vegetarian I could
imagine
like eating beef one less meal a week or
two less meals a week and I can imagine
you telling me things that would
persuade me to some extent and that's
the kind of conversation that the spirit
of the conversation that we really need
to be having our environmentalist is
going to be upset with my approach of
course because environmentalists get
upset about everything and advocates get
upset about everything and that's
frankly part of their job they are not
level-headed legislators and they are
not people who live in my house with me
making decisions that are very personal
to my family I'm glad that they're out
there I'm glad that PETA exists in the
world
despite the fact that I disagree with so
many of the things that they say and do
but they're good at creating noise in
the margin for us to look at and to
remember I mean do you wonder if if when
it comes to PETA for example or some of
the members of the environmental
movement
if the alarmism actually undercut
support for ability to do things meaning
that it's enervating there's this
there's this push on some parts of the
radical environmentalist movement as you
see in the animal rights movement PETA
where they're PETA will do Holocaust on
your plate my first reaction is I'm
gonna go eat a bucket of chicken right
now because a chicken is not a human
being and when you say that this is like
a Holocaust my answer is no it's not
when it comes to climate change it's
sort of the same thing when I see people
saying well it's gonna be the day after
tomorrow and Dennis Quaid is going to be
wandering across the ski slopes in the
middle of New York and that's gonna
happen next year and all of Miami is
gonna be under water I mean I saw a
story just this week about somebody
saying well if all the ice caps melted
then all of Florida would be gone right
and if an asteroid hits earth we'll all
be dead I mean I think that's that's not
useful talk yeah well I would say a
couple of things first of all my
instinct isn't the same as yours I don't
rush off to eat the chicken I would rush
off to condemn Peters rhetoric right no
like no I don't have it I don't have a
reflexive I don't rise to meet the anger
that inspired them to I think that's
there and and secondly I want to know if
an asteroid is coming toward Earth I
want scientists working on it and if
scientists say to me that's really no
threat or that's a threat that we just
can't do anything about then I won't
sleep soundly not stressing out about
asteroids if there are five or six
papers that say all the florida's gonna
be underwater in three years I'd say I
really need to realm or you know an
analogy that I often think about is if I
were to get a cancer diagnosis you know
if I went in for a regular physical my
physician calls me and says your
bloodwork came up a little bit weird I
think it would be good to get a more
extensive check by a cancer expert
I wouldn't go and amputate my limbs I
wouldn't go and sign up for chemotherapy
the next day I'd say who's the best
doctor I want to go to the best doctor
do I trust doctors absolutely No
do I trust them more than I trust myself
with medicine of course I do
if that doctor said to me we have
reasons to be concerned you know here's
what I would prescribe I'd say I want to
get a second opinion especially if the
prescription was something really
dramatic that I did not want to do like
chemotherapy if the second doctor said I
think this is serious I would also
suggest chemotherapy perhaps a slightly
different course of it but I'd say I
want to talk to a third doctor there is
a number of doctors that I would talk to
or even though this the accumulation of
their advice would leave some
uncertainty there's enough doctors that
I would talk to where I'd say I need to
take action I don't know if this is the
best action but it is the one that's
been most widely recommended to me by
experts who have no strong incentive to
send me through chemotherapy so what are
my choices my choices are to live with
it for a while and see what happens or
to try to be proactive and and treated
in advance of it metastasizing so what
we know is that people who wait usually
die or at the very least their quality
of life is radically inhibited they're
not able to work afterwards they're not
able to lift their children into the air
they're not able to enjoy meals they
can't trout all of the things that we
make like valuable I wouldn't want that
fate so chemo strikes me as something
that would be incredibly to experience
and I would do just about anything to
avoid but there are times when it's
justified so you know my attitude about
this I'm not a climate expert I'm not a
scientist
you know I assume you would describe
yourself the same way yeah of course I'm
somebody who tries to read and I and I
tried to read broadly you know as much
as I can everything I have read has
suggested that this is an unambiguous
situation I'm not talking about
projections a hundred years out or 200
years out I don't know what coastal
cities might flood or not I know that
there are very good reasons to think
we're going to have a lot of flooding
including the fact that we already have
it seems to me sensible to start to make
changes one thing that that you
said before which I was taken with is
that humans are good at adapting and I
that rings true to me the question is
when do we start adapting right so is
interesting I was over the weekend I was
reading a book called climate casino by
William Nordhaus is the Nobel Prize in
Economics winner talking specifically
about sort of the range of outcomes that
are possible here one of the things that
makes the conversation so difficult is
that there is this wide variety of
outcomes that are possible and there are
I would say unrealistic assessments of
what we can do and more realistic
assessments of what we can do so for
example the Copenhagen Accords suggest
that we are supposed to keep to a two
degree climate change maximum it's not
going to happen I mean Nordhaus makes
clear that there's effectively no chance
of that he sort of suggests that we aim
for four degrees Celsius there are
real-time costs to the stuff that we are
doing now we have to weigh those against
the future costs that may accrue to an
economy that for example will be a lot
more developed at a hundred years a lot
of places that are impoverished now will
presumably not be impoverished after a
hundred years of development but the
cost that we're talking about incurring
now our cost that will be incurred right
now and largely not by the people who
are who were talking about like right
what now we're talking about the people
in the first world's we're gonna read
your book are gonna watch this show but
the people who really are gonna be cost
the most if we cut back on carbon fuels
for example are the people on the second
in the third world people who are living
lifespans of 40 45 years and who are
burning dung for fuel and so in weighing
the risks and the and the costs and the
benefits I feel like it's the the
conversation has become too simplified
there are folks who just say we need to
act we need act now and it's it's
chemotherapy and then we don't define
what the chemotherapy looks like who
actually pays the cost of the
chemotherapy and what the possibility is
that the cancer is actually livable and
this is where you know the without
treatment you mean our livable with
treatment oh well depends on the
treatment so there are three types of
treatment in in my view and I think Nord
House is right on this he says that to
break it down you there's adaptation
which is the idea people are going to
move from the coast you're going to see
certain popular migrations from
particular areas over the course of the
next century which is already happening
and for all the talk about that's a
crisis
well again we're talking about migration
over the course of 100 years now the
kind of wave you're seeing from Syria
into Europe which is the result of a
right now crisis everybody moving that
so there's also seeing it in California
right now as wildfires you know
wildfires the the wildfire season right
around here right is now 20 percent
longer than it was two decades ago right
and you are seeing people move out of
out of those towns but I think the stuff
that people are talking about
geopolitically is cross-border crises of
millions of people swamp ignores it
seems like that will be a more gradual
problem than a sudden problem what makes
you think that it would be a more
gradual problem that over the course of
the next hundred years the climate is
going to gradually change unless you hit
an inflection point in which case the
climate spikes dramatically let's talk
about that what happens if we hit that
inflection point
are you with you we don't know we don't
know what an election point is but you
just said I think that's right right so
how do we deal with that uncertainty so
that that is that that's exactly the
question I'm asking so when it comes to
that uncertainty is the greater risk
taking catastrophic climate get climate
action to cut down on carbon fuels in a
dramatic way or is adaptation a better
solution in terms of assuming that over
the course of the next century there
will be certain damage that is done by
natural disasters people moving across
borders in other words there's the
possibility that we get hit by a car
tomorrow how much life insurance do you
take out right and that is yeah that's
dependent on the premiums it's dependent
on how much money you have in the bank
account and so what makes the
conversation so difficult is on the one
side people failing to acknowledge that
you could hit a tipping point and things
could get disastrous and on the other
side people inevitably assuming that we
definitely will hit a tipping point and
it will be a disaster and thus we have
to do catastrophic things to the
American economy for example that hurt
lots of people I mean you hurt the
American economy you're gonna hurt
everybody's economy and how would you
compare those catastrophic outcomes of
acting with the catastrophic outcomes of
mass migration in the United States or
the catastrophic outcomes of widespread
drought or the catastrophic outcomes of
superstorm you know I mean Nordhaus
tries to now analyze this in sort of an
economic fashion looking at how much GDP
globally what it would he forecast that
it would
cost four there'd be a rise in natural
disasters as forecast by the IPCC over
the course of the next hundred years and
that sort of thing what he what he
suggests is that the biggest damage will
be in these sort of environmental area
not the industrial area so the economy
will basically be pretty pretty durable
that people have a good way of adapting
when it comes to economics and even in
terms of rising disease he thinks that
will be fairly mild but in terms of sort
of environmental damage itself ocean
acidification destruction of coral reefs
that sort of stuff you will see deep
damage and so if you cared a lot about
that sort of stuff then obviously graver
necessity must be taken so I guess when
it comes to remedies to get back to sort
of the model I'm talking about there's
there's adaptation which is not the only
model and then there is geoengineering
which folks are talking about as a
possible solution the possibility of
shooting sulphur into the air to cool
temperatures or using properties to make
the earth less dark in color so that it
reflects more sunlight back into back
outside and lowers the global
temperature there's been talk about that
and and obviously tech not a
psychological and then there's been
heavy focus put on mitigation and the
mitigation is stuff you really talk
about in the book so in your view what
are the proper measures of mitigation
that we should be taking and how much
would be focusing on again what
individuals do and how much you would be
focusing on what governments ought to be
doing in terms of mitigation because
that seems like where all the focus is
right now because you can't predict what
technology is going to do and you can't
really predict to a degree of certainty
the sort of tipping points that we're
talking about hmm so I think that
there's a danger in a temptation to have
the conversation quickly accelerate to
the ends like in a hundred years we're
gonna have five degrees of warming this
is what the apocalyptic scenarios will
look like these are the most dramatic
possible solutions or mitigations right
like sending coming making the earth
darker mm-hmm you know that that's
radical or lighter yeah yeah so what we
know is that in order to reach the goals
of the Paris Accord which people now
estimate as we have about a five percent
likelihood it's not happened yeah but to
do that citizens have to have an
individual carbon
of about 4.5 million pounds per year the
I'm sorry 42.3 the average right now is
4.5 so we have to somehow close that
distance there's a huge difference
between like an American's carbon budget
and a Bangladeshis carbon budget which
is important and we can talk about but a
two-thirds vegan diet which is what this
book is talking about refraining from
eating animal products for breakfast and
lunch and then for dinner you eat
whatever you want closes that gap by 1.3
so this is not a small thing and however
much you might dislike that notion and I
have to say I really dislike the notion
of eating that way I am I've been a
vegetarian on and off for most of my
life
but I'm not the kind of vegetarian who
finds me disgusting quite the opposite I
always want to eat it I mean I think it
smells amazing I think it looks amazing
and I think tastes amazing so I am not
proposing this as somebody who finds it
easy I have no idea what your eating
habits are but I would guess that I find
it more I would find this more difficult
than you not having been said do I find
it radical like do I find it impossible
do I feel like anybody is grabbing
something from my plate do I feel like a
choice is being forced upon me or
restricted no I feel like this is the
least I can do I think this is something
I can do there's an analogy to Homefront
efforts during World War two which I
write about at length in the book the
world the homefront efforts would not
have won the war obviously on their own
but we couldn't have won the war without
Homefront efforts without having people
agreeing to carpool I'm having a
national speed limit of 35 miles an hour
the highest income tax rate was 94
percent during the war and the income
that qualified for that tax was dropped
25 fold their rations on food these are
things that nobody likes
but everybody agreed to we're not in a
war or if we are it doesn't feel like we
are it feels like it's something that's
happening over there then close at home
so
harder to make the kind of emotional
connections or even the intellectual
connections that would inspire one to
change but the kinds of changes that
we're talking about if we are really
just looking at the numbers and looking
at the science are not radical and
they're not impractical and they will
not be the solution but they will be an
enormous part of the solution and I
don't know if you've read there's an
article in The Guardian
a day or two ago about a leaked report
from the next IPCC report that said we
have no hope of reaching Paris Accord
goals or anything like them without
really changing how we farm how we eat
and how we manage land so what I prefer
is instead of you know reaching for a
kind of hypothetical scenario that
frankly I have no control over in any
case that I that is like too complicated
to really converse about in any kind of
sensible detail to think about what's a
starting point you know so if I were to
ask you first of all do you tend to
agree with the idea that animal
agriculture is a huge part of the
problem I mean statistically speaking
obviously agriculture represents 125
percent of carbon emissions so yeah so
there's the the we don't know exactly
how many because this is the other thing
these are all interlinked systems and
extraordinarily complicated but it's at
least 25 percent and some estimates put
it closer to 50 percent it all depends
on what you include in your calculation
so the people who say 25 percent are
including all the carbon that is
released when we clear-cut rainforests
right which is 80 percent of the time is
done for animal agriculture 91% of
Amazon clear-cutting is done for animal
agriculture but it's not including the
ways that the amount of carbon that
those trees would absorb so it's a
little bit like a life insurance policy
that covers the funeral but not your
lost wages you know it doesn't make a
lot of sense so this is very well
established you don't find people who
think about and who know about the climb
change science who would disagree with
the idea that animal agriculture is if
not the leading cause a heavy driver I
mean a little question ok so if we start
with that right this is a truth so what
do we do with that truth I don't feel
and I would be very surprised if you
felt that people should have choices
taken away from them right I don't feel
that we should have no hamburgers
available in supermarkets or restaurants
I do feel that they could be labeled
differently without giving us a little
bit more information about where the
food comes from what the practices of
the farms are information that frankly
is very very similar to the information
we have on our refrigerators on our a/c
units on pretty much anything you buy
these days washers and dryers and cars
inform us let us make good decisions I
think that we should hold the meat
industry accountable for its
environmental destruction you know a
company like Smithfield had 8,000
violations of the Clean Water Act in one
year so if they had 10 you would say
shame on them if they had a hundred you
would say we need better oversight 8,000
is a business model and it's the
business model of animal agriculture to
create environmental destruction not
because they want to in and of itself
but because it's a good business model
if your idea of a good business is only
making money so we should change
subsidies change regulations so the
price so the price of meat is just what
the price of meat is and we should ask
ourselves what's possible for me right
I'm not asking this in an abstract way
of every person on earth because
different people will have different
answers for good reasons there are
people in the country who live in urban
food deserts where they just don't have
access to any food that isn't McDonald's
that's a shame we need to work on that
problem rather than sight those people
as a reason why you and I would have you
know not want to eat less meat I mean
that does raise the the
collective-action problem though so
obviously there are a billion people
living in China billion people living in
India and those folks are gonna eat what
those folks are going to eat those of us
in Europe or the United States just
largely where our audiences let's say
they reduce their their meat consumption
heavily but that meat consumption is not
reduced in places like China or India
in many places in the world make
consumption is growing as prosperity
grows so are you asking people to do
something that's in vain we'll get to
that in just one second but first I'll
be honest I'm too busy to go to the post
office the last time I went I got a
giant parking ticket because let me tell
you something about LA they suck at
everything the LA City authorities but
when it comes to giving you a parking
ticket they are there boom just like
that so no more post office for me when
I need to mail something I use stamps
calm it is fast and it is easy
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the u.s. post office direct
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps.com can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it your mail carrier or
drop it in a mailbox it is indeed that
simple with stamps calm you can get five
cents off every first-class stamp plus
up to 40% off Priority Mail which is a
hell of a deal
stamps calm it's a no-brainer it saves
you time it saves you money there's a
reason we use it here at daily wire just
like 700,000 other small businesses are
to use stamps calm right now my
listeners get a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale no long term
commitment which again is a fantastic
deal just go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in Shapiro that stamps calm enter
code Shapiro again stamps calm code
Shapiro so I'm actually warm toward
toward your recommendation because I
love the idea of individuals taking on
things themselves as opposed to having a
cram down from the top and I I do wonder
at the collective-action problem that
sort of inherent here so India is the
most vegetarian country in the world
right China recently created an
initiative and initiative to reduce meat
consumption by half by 2030 it's
incredible are they going to achieve it
no but what an incredible thing for
environmental reasons that was why they
did it and we have like American
celebrities over there doing commercials
during public service announcements to
encourage the Chinese public to think
about meat differently now the question
is I think about it how differently
think about in some sort of futuristic
I'm going to be e to drinking Soylent
and like eating little pills for dinner
no to think about it like their parents
thought about it and that's what we need
to do here this is
conservative eating it's not radical
eating we eat in America now a hundred
and eighty times as much chicken per
person as we did a century ago we eat
the equipment the equivalent of every
citizen in the world in the year seven
seventeen hundred eighteen nine hundred
pounds of beef and twelve hundred
gallons of milk every day obviously a
lot of that is because of the population
explosion but a lot of it is because of
the meat explosion what are we getting
for this you know it used to be the case
like our parents when they would eat
chicken it would be roasted they would
buy it probably from somebody they knew
the techniques for raising the chicken
would have resembled nature cycles you
know animals living outside animals that
did not need antibiotics animals that
did not have to be slaughtered after 30
days lest their body weight crush their
bones which is the case now eating
animals that are capable of sexual
reproduction every turkey you've ever
eaten in your life was incapable of
sexual reproduction so does that sound
conservative is that what we think of
when we conjure them you know a mental
image of a farm or does that sound like
something that's being forced on us
however subtly 20% of meals in America
are now eaten in cars you know if we're
eating all this chicken it's not because
somebody's roasting it in the oven every
night and we're eating it at a table
that's set with plates and silverware
and the place where families transmit
values and tell stories we're eating
McNuggets so what we need is not to do
something that feels weird we need to do
something feels good we need to do
something that resembles the kind of
eating's that are eating that our
parents and grandparents did where meat
was not you know a meal was not a slab
of meat that covered 60% of a plate it
included all kinds of other things and
there was some amount of meat and I
think we can do that I don't think it's
a pipe dream if you were to ask me what
are the odds that half of Americans or
half of Europeans or half of Chinese are
going to be vegetarians in ten years I
would say zero what are the odds that
half of the meals eaten in America and
in Europe and in China are vegetarian in
ten years I would say I think that could
happen I don't know if it's likely but I
think it could happen and for me the
best way of moving into that thought
experiment and to moving and hopefully
into into a kind of optimism about it
and an empowerment is to engage it on a
person-by-person basis so like I'm
sitting across from you right you've
acknowledged the climate change is
happening because of human activities
you've acknowledged that it is going to
be a problem at some point we don't know
how big a problem it's gonna be we don't
know when it's gonna be a problem at
some point the kinds of adaptations
you've talked about are suggestive that
of you're thinking it's gonna be a big
problem if people are gonna have to you
know leave cities that that's a big
problem you agree that animal
agriculture is if not the most important
thing that an individual can do changing
our relationship to animal agriculture
if it's not the most important thing
it's one of the most important things so
what's what seems possible to you I'm
not talking legislatively you're
probably just in your own feels what I
say as I say you know I don't know how
big a problem climate change is going to
be but I also hear the idea that on an
individual level if there's something
that I can do to mitigate the chances of
bad things happening in the future and
on an honest level if it's not at too
much cost to me in my personal life then
I'm willing to do it that's one of the
things that I actually do enjoy about
the book is that you actually talk about
your own struggles with the you know I'm
a crusader I'm a visionary I'm gonna do
this and then tomorrow you're eating
kind of what you want you know and that
that is that is part of it I do wonder
you know you talk in the book about you
sort of compare this to the crusade
against tobacco that happened in the
United States and I wonder if that is
because it wasn't really a moral crusade
against tobacco that was a you're
preserving your own health crusade and
it's you're preserving your own health
in real time it's not you're saving your
grandkids right it's not you're saving
in a hundred years maybe your great
grandchild is gonna have to move from
Miami inland to Tallahassee or something
it was you're gonna die of cancer or if
you keep smoking and is the better pitch
for I've said before on my own show that
I when it comes to moral issues there
are certain moral issues where we look
back in 100 150 years and we say how
could people have ever done that that's
insane right obviously slavery Jim Crow
come to mind in the modern context but
I've said I think on abortion 50 years
from now people will go crazy but I
think certainly on the
arianism I think in a hundred years when
it is possible for people to get the
protein that they need increasingly it's
happening now without having to kill
animals then they're gonna look back and
say who are these barbarians who are
slaughtering animals and mass numbers
and not only that there's fairly good
research that suggests that heavy intake
of anything from chicken to to beef less
so fish but chicken and beef is actually
not very good for you to have you in
taken of those is gonna is going to hurt
you health-wise why not make the health
pitch as opposed to making a global
warming pitch specifically because it
feels like you're being moralized at on
global warming you know in the in the
book you make comparisons to people who
kind of look the other way during the
Holocaust for example why why make one
picture as opposed to the other and
you've made the other pitch in in eating
animals for example well I would make
both pitches you know and and the
smoking analogy is a good one because we
knew for a very long time that smoking
caused cancer and it's taken I mean
people talk about it as a triumph you
know our ability to cut smoking as we
have and I look at it as a failure it's
just taken way too long given all the
information that we have I would add
that smokers are three times as likely
to die of cancer as non-smokers people
who eat diets heavy in animal protein
are four times as likely to die of
cancer as people who are vegetarian so
it's a rather startling statistic that
if the if what you want to do is avoid
death by cancer you'd be better
continuing to smoke and and stop eating
burgers there are a lot of ways of
thinking about these issues and I think
a little bit of moralizing isn't the
worst thing in the world you know when
you were just we disagree about abortion
but when when you were just talking
about it as something that we will look
back at in 50 years and say how could
they have that's moralizing and I
disagree with you but I'm glad that you
feel the way that you do I'm glad that
your opinion is not only informed by
information but informed by passion and
you care and when something bad is
happening something we perceive that is
wrong I think it's a good thing to speak
up even if it risks a certain amount of
alienation even if
risks sounding condescending even if it
risks as I have risked at many many a
dinner party coming off like an apple
like an annoying soul you know you risk
that right pretty much every day yeah
and the risk doesn't always pay off I'll
tell you but but but you're you I would
say a couple of things in response to
that one is what are the options like to
keep your mouth shut or to moderate
everything until it means nothing
also time matters there's an urgency to
these problems you know again I don't
agree with you about abortion but
somebody who holds your opinion you this
every day matters right yeah of course
and no when I look at factory farming
there are 50 billion animals being
factory farmed right now I'm every year
in the world time matters the conditions
matter and this is another thing that I
think we need to think about again and
it's a kind of movement away from the
binary to the to the specific into the
process we are not all going to die
because of climate change or at least I
don't see that happening and it experts
don't really see that happening it's not
apocalyptic it's a question of how much
are we willing to lose because we're
gonna lose a lot we're gonna lose the
coral reefs we're gonna probably lose
the Amazon and how much of this loss are
we comfortable with how many people have
to become how many tens of millions how
many hundreds of millions of people have
to become climate refugees before we say
now that's a number too high for me how
many days a year do you want your kids
to be able to play outside before you
say that's too few like how many species
have to be lost this is what you know
getting back to the kind of the point
that I was making earlier this is where
I think that the conversation about what
we can do in a personal level is more
appealing to me than the Doomsday talk
because once again into doomsday talk
then what I hear coming down the rails
is green New Deal destroy the American
economy if we really want to fight this
problem bomb all the coal factories in
China and India and finish this thing
off right now because otherwise you know
we're all doomed why make the global
warming pitch which I gotta say is a lot
more off-putting than some
of the other pitches that you've made
we'll get to that in just one second
first they seem like a friend or even
family you trust them with your life but
behind the promises of fame success
riches beyond your wildest dreams it's
just another scam or trying to cheat you
out of your life savings but every
single week the podcast original con
artist dives into the psychology of
hustlers and swindlers and fraudsters to
share with you the greatest cons of all
time are the worst cons of all time
con artists come from all different
walks of life this podcast covers all of
them Theron o--'s founder and CEO
Elizabeth Holmes grew her company to a
value of nine billion dollars despite
the fact that its flagship technology
didn't actually work that's sort of a
hitch there Jordan Belfort also known as
the wolf of Wall Street party hard made
millions while engaging in stock market
manipulation Bernie Madoff top Wall
Street market maker who operated one of
the biggest Ponzi schemes in history con
thousands of clients out of a combined
sixty five billion dollars spot the con
before it finds you listen to the
podcast con artists search for and
subscribe to con artists on Spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts again
search con artists or visit part cast
dot-com slash con artists to listen
right now okay so the argument that as a
mitigation against future risk and as a
personal benefit to your own health you
should eat less meat that seems
perfectly reasonable to me once we get
into it's a crisis it's a crisis that
has to be handled right now or human
beings will inevitably meet with harsh
consequences that are uh that are that
are unsustainable I think there's a lot
more play in those joints and frankly I
think that on an emotional level you can
get into a situation that proves too
much meaning if it's that big a deal
where do you draw the line in terms of
well this far I'm not willing to go so
the solution they're proposing sounds a
lot more reasonable than the rhetoric
that maybe you're pushing in order to
get to that solution I can be easily
convinced by the idea that I should eat
less meat in fact I'm fairly well
convinced that you're right that people
should eat less meat them I'm pretty
much ready to get on board I've been
trying to do some of it myself
the question becomes in the in the
rhetoric that we that we use about
climate change and it forces a binary
choice between sort of all and nothing
then I don't think you're actually
proposing in your solutions no I'm not
but
at the same time I'm not proposing the
attitude of I can sort of see that I can
imagine trying like if we're going to be
serious about individual responsibility
and individual choice as opposed to the
things that you have a you buck against
which are kind of you know legislation
are enforced in the absence of choice
right then we have to be really serious
about the choices that we're making and
not take them lightly there's a there is
a responsibility that you take on when
you frame this as something that you are
going to do so just to push you a little
bit you know you have said you can
imagine this this is something that
you're starting to try so if we just
walk through it in specifics right you
[Music]
are going to have dinner tonight so can
you imagine at your dinner tonight just
to begin with not eating red meat take
that as a starting point
I mean sure that's not that's easy can
you say you won't I can you would say
you won't yeah lunch period beef tonight
it also happens to be when we're filming
this the nine days so I'm actually
Jewish a law forbidding from eating or
meeting me tonight but sure even even if
even if we weren't there's a wonderful
analog to kashu by the way we may not
get around to that
can you imagine breakfasts I don't know
about you but for me breakfast is like
not that yeah I got pretty light on
breakfast
can you imagine saying I been Shapiro
I'm not gonna eat animal products at
breakfast yep I pretty much don't now so
not I pretty much don't know can you say
like I just won't do it this matters to
me I am somebody who puts his money
where his mouth is I've just said
climate change is happening I've just
acknowledged that animal agriculture is
the most important thing that I can do
my relationship to foods the most
portent thing I can do as an individual
and I've said I don't want other people
forcing me to make changes so I'm taking
it upon myself to make changes so what
stops you from saying I won't the
capacity for human said in the fact that
I like creamer my coffee every so often
well I would say those infringement on a
kind of model of living don't undermine
it okay that's another thing we really
have to move away from is these
identities of what are you I'm a
vegetarian where are you I'm a vegan
what do
pescetarian and then that's what I'm
saying I mean I'm saying that the
measures that you're calling for are
actually relatively moderate in terms of
what human beings can do and that's why
instead of me just saying hard and fast
I'm never gonna eat animal products at
breakfast again me saying that most of
the time I can I can commit that most of
the time I won't eat animal products at
breakfast that's something that I feel
like is reasonable and something that I
can do saying bar none I'm never gonna
need an animal product at breakfast
again that's necessary right but there's
a huge difference and saying you know
it's why religion works right if you
said I'm gonna really do my best not to
eat pork that's not what you say right I
assume correct
you say I'm just not gonna do it it's a
good question I mean I'm not firmly
convinced that it is morally sinful to
eat animal products in the same way that
it would be for me to violate the word
of god for example in my religious
belief and that's well the Word of God
is also not to inflict harm on
unnecessary harm on other living things
not to desecrate God's creations to be
good stewards of the earth right I would
say it but I know I'm perfectly extends
to this again that that's that's a very
strict reading of eating a hamburger
that that is that that unless you
visited a factory farm it's really not I
can pretty much promise you that if you
and I traveled not that far from here
and went to a factory farm you would say
this is grossly out of line with my
Jewish values so again this is the case
for vegetarianism that I like better
than the global warming case is when I
was saying earlier this is the case that
you make on an ethical level for not
eating animals or on a health level for
not eating animals is an argument that I
actually like better than the some time
in the foreseeable future there will be
consequences that we can't exactly
forecast but know some will be harmful
that's that's harder because we're not
going to know until we get there how bad
things are going to be and and sort of
projecting that back into the present is
a lot more difficult than saying here
and now there's something bad that's
going on I totally respect that
and I see no reason why they're never
really exclusive but I'm sure that's
exactly the environmental argument can
add to the other arguments that are
maybe more persuasive to you there's no
reason in the world that should detract
right now I agree with that so and
that's that's why I guess I'm
pushing back a little bit against the
extent of the rhetoric on the
environmental stuff just because that
stuff is harder on an individual level
to know than it is to know that it's
mistreatment of an animal to cage it in
a small cage where I can't move and grow
it beyond all boundaries where its bones
collapse in on itself so I know you
believe it or not there there are a lot
of people on earth who feel just the
opposite who would say I'm extremely
concerned about the fate of our planet
and the kind of what I'm going to leave
for my children and grandchildren
great-grandchildren and animals are kind
of just animals like it's regrettable
but it's not a big deal to me so one of
the really interesting things about
thinking about animal products is how
differently different people respond
some people are only compelled by the
animal welfare argument some people are
only compelled by the environmental
argument and there are an awful lot of
people who are only compelled by
personal health it is a comprehensive
argument there is no argument that I
know of in favor of eating meat
indiscriminately you know that's again
all of that is fair I think that the the
reason I'm bucking me a little bit and
fighting back against you a little bit
on the global warming stuff particularly
is because with the the moral case
against eating animal products you know
on the basis of Cruelty to Animals
there's a particular problem that has an
obvious solution when it comes to the
when it comes to the health case there's
a particular problem that has an obvious
solution when it comes to global warming
because of the inherent vagary of the
forecast in the future as I say anywhere
from 2 degrees Celsius to 6 degrees
Celsius with tipping points that we
don't know where they exist we don't
know what future technologies are going
to be it becomes a little bit less
obvious and you are going to encounter
particularly on the right accusations
that I think in some cases not your case
but I certainly know people are
justified of virtue signaling that what
you're really implying is that I don't
care about my own grandkids if I eat
this hamburger whereas I think that you
can much more easily make the argument
that yeah I care about my grandkids I
disagree with you about the extent to
which global warming is going to be a
full-scale disaster if I eat this
hamburger but where I can't argue with
you is on a topic where you know more
and have seen more which is the cruelty
to animals or the health effects of
eating meat what is wrong with virtue
signaling what's wrong with
saying we know for sure this is not
ambiguous this is not controversial you
will not if you can find somebody I you
know to come in and join us I will fly
back here and have that conversation if
you can find somebody who will say
animal agriculture is not a huge
environmental problem and by the way
we're not just talking about climate
change you know the UN has said it's
among the top two or three causes of
every significant environmental we know
we agreed on that so there's in water
pollution deforestation loss of
biodiverse this goes back to the okay so
why are you calling on people to do
two-thirds meat reduction as opposed to
complete meat reduction like no meat at
all that is an excellent question and
one that I wrestled with and in part I
think I was responding to my own limits
I am NOT a vegan do I know that it would
be the the right way to live according
to all the arguments made yes but then
we run into this problem which is really
interesting and fruitful and fun and
productive to talk about because it can
actually nudge us and nudge the other
toward behaving more in line with one's
ideals like acting more like the person
you want to be it would certainly be
better for the environment it would
certainly be better for our health and
it'd be better for animals to go all the
way
I don't realistically see that happening
and I think it's extraordinarily
important and urgently important to move
forward instead of measuring it the
distance from some sort of ethical
perfection that nobody's going to
achieve any way to measure the distance
from doing nothing and breakfast is a
place to start
if I were to ask everybody in this room
I don't know maybe there's what 10
people in this room right now hey who
here thinks they can never eat animal
products again I think it's extremely
unlikely anybody would say me if I were
to say who thinks it's possible Nazi
damn it all
animal products for breakfast tomorrow I
think everybody would say yes fairly
straightforwardly if I were to say lunch
it would be it would be harder but we
could have a conversation and it would
have to be an ongoing conversation and
one that's had not between me and each
person but between each person and
himself you know
just a moment of pause and it's really
tricky I know this from experience
because you know to be frank I hate it I
really hate it like I have cravings you
know I love the taste of meat I also
love the functions it serves like I love
family barbecues I loved that my
grandmother would show her love through
a particular chicken dish that she would
always make I loved the fourth of July I
love Thanksgiving
it sucks to give these things up and if
I were a lion my obligations would end
with my cravings but I'm not a lion I'm
a human being you know you often hear
people say well the human brain wouldn't
have evolved to be what it is if we
hadn't eaten meat throughout history
which is true the question now is what
do we do with these big brains that we
have and what distinguishes us from the
other animals is the ability to override
our cravings with reason which is
something we do constantly you could
probably think of a hundred examples of
your having done that today there's a
balance which we've now touched on in a
number of Leuven aspects of what's too
much to ask right because there is a
point at which it's just too much to ask
and we might have different ideas about
what's too much to ask are there
legislatively or within our own lives
but it is good and necessary to figure
out what that is in your own life and to
really challenge yourself
so when you say yeah I could probably do
it that doesn't sound to me like you
challenging yourself you say like I'm
gonna do it and if I you know fall short
I'm not gonna beat myself up I'm not
gonna suddenly see myself as somebody
who isn't trying I'm not gonna I mean
the term fallen vegetarian is just makes
me want to like pull my ears off of my
face you know like following sure why
don't worry about the other you know
you're trying to do something good I try
to tell the truth right as much as I can
if my mom comes down the stairs she's
wearing a dress she says do I look nice
in this dress I'm gonna say yes right
whatever she whatever even if it's not
my favorite that doesn't then make me
feel like oh there goes my attempt to be
a truth teller I'm gonna now
lies at every available opportunity no
instead I look at my self as somebody
who wants to tell the truth not as a
religious identity not as an inflexible
identity but as an effort that I'm
constantly making and constantly making
because it's informed by an argument
that I'm constantly having with myself
it's just not easy and I think eating is
exactly the same we need to move away
from do you realize your shoes or
leather by the way my shoes are leather
do you realize that this was in that
meal and move much toward something like
congratulating each other really that's
really cool that you're trying that's
amazing but the trying has to be serious
and it can't be the amount of trying
that is effortless or is comfortable but
the amount of trying that approaches our
our limit no I I am now doing everything
I can do and imagine the world if we
applied that standard isn't that
everything that you're saying here is
the most appealing part of what you say
so what are the practical steps that you
see toward getting individuals to do
this sort of stuff so you're going
through this exercise with me a minute
ago and we can continue on the exercise
I actually would like to hear how you
would approach this with somebody like
what's what sort of commitment would you
look for from from somebody and how
would you get them to do it because I
again I think that the what what
religion has been pretty good at is
getting people to feel a moral
obligation that the downside of religion
generally is is the shaming culture and
I think everybody sort of feels that and
the problem with environmentalism is the
shaming culture as well as soon as you
feel that you're being shamed you're out
so how do you get people to to do this
one of the practical steps people should
take I'm with you like I'm out when I
get shamed and this is something I
believe in very strongly I just turn off
you know I do I lose interest and
there's a funny thing about climate
change which is despite how broad and
serious a problem is it's really easy to
get bored with or it's very easy to stop
thinking about both because we have such
strong incentives not to think about it
and because as it's been described it is
maybe the most boring subject that's
ever had to be brought to the public
most boring scientific subject so what
is my strategy there's a reason I'm here
right like when I told people I was
going to be on this
with you a lot of them said like why
mm-hmm I wanted to be here with you
because you're a thoughtful guy and
you're very smart guy and my sense
having listened to you a lot is that you
are open and you're not open to you'll
meet an attack with an attack but you
will meet like an extended hand with an
extended hand and I have no interest in
attacking your position because frankly
I'd be attacking my own position which
is we are both in different ways and
perhaps the different extents climate
change deniers like in the sense that we
are not doing anything with what we know
you know we're talking a lot we're
sharing opinions which is useful but in
our own lives we're not doing very much
my dream was to come here and to hear
you out and as we've exactly as we've
been doing and to hear you say I could
try that seems like something I could
try you have an enormous reach if you
were to turn to whichever camera and say
to the two million people who you know
watch you and listen to you hey guys I'm
not telling you what to do this is not a
religion I'm not being hysterical no
one's taking anything away from you but
there are some facts we only to agree on
a sensible people and we should really
try to eat less of this kind of food you
can decide for yourself what less means
now and you know honestly I'm willing to
do that like right now into the camera I
think the the biggest problem that the
folks have and the pushback is always
going to be exactly the same that you're
issuing which is which is why this is
effective it's why this conversation is
good which is okay so I say I do that
and then the next thing is yet you drive
a car get you flying a plane but this is
on the I know you haven't and that's why
I'm saying that your appeal is different
it's why I enjoy having this
conversation it's why I think that the
AOC agree New Deal appeal felt
completely flat because the idea there
was we're gonna completely remake the
American economy no more no more flying
no more hamburgers no more of anything
of the things that you like because the
problem is just that urgent what I like
about your approach is that it is
multifaceted and multi rational
that you're using yes the environment as
a as a push point on eating habits but
that that is combined with other reasons
why you shouldn't be doing all of this
so this is all it's good for you for a
variety of reasons why you should be
doing this and that you're not coming at
it from a perspective of now we're going
to shame you is why you get the pushback
from the right very often from from a
lot of folks who are environmentalist
well you took a private jet to to this
particular Davos meeting to talk about
climate change and you took your limo
there well the approach that you're
taking is is one that sort of forecloses
that because you're basically saying we
all do the best that we can and the best
that we can means pushing yourself a
little bit more that I think is a much
better approach and frankly I wish that
more people would take it I think we
could talk about flying as well like
there is zero chance that I'm going to
stop flying there's zero chance that
you're going to stop flying there's zero
chance that the American public is going
to stop flying can I imagine taking one
less flight a year I think yeah that's
actually fairly easy to imagine I like
going on camping trips with my kids like
we could take a train we could take a
car can I imagine taking two less trips
a year this is the goal I've now set for
myself taking two less trips a year
creates a huge impact a really
significant impact if we could start at
the beginning rather than at the end you
know I think you would find a lot of
people not only being open to that but
being inspired by that you know and I'm
not again I'm not talking about students
on the Berkeley campus I'm talking about
everybody who watches well you're
starting from normal human behavior then
you're just say okay we can ratchet it
down a degree as opposed to what would
our ideal human look like they'd live in
a cave not using fire and they would
never contribute anything to the to the
climate change environment contribute
any carbon emissions and so how close
can we get to back again I'm praising
your approach and I'm hoping that more
people who are on the environmentalist
side of the ledger where I mean frankly
I consider myself an environmentalist of
laughter of I'm sure many many people
I'm left you to see I don't know anybody
there's nothing laughable about that
again the way we started this
conversation was your description of
climate change which is perfectly
in agreement with the most liberal Jews
I mean I talk to professors at Cal Tech
about this thesis then it's pretty
obvious what exactly the problem is that
the range of outcomes is less obvious
and then what government action should
look like in response to that range of
outcomes is even less obvious than that
because that is a variety of policies
with uncertain ends but again what
you're pushing is something that is a
religious person it appeals to me I like
the idea of taking on additional burdens
it's something that I actually enjoy and
I think it breeds a certain level of
responsibility so for folks in my
audience who may not be familiar with
your work or or what you've done in
where do you come from what's you've
what's your background well shame on
them for not knowing where do I come
from I was born and raised in DC but my
parents weren't involved in government
as you know there's a population in DC
that's transient and a population that's
permanent and so my family was part of
the permanent population that is after
my grandparents emigrated my mother was
actually born in a DP camp in Poland and
came shortly after the war and
experienced a kind of American dream my
grandparents spoke virtually no English
when they arrived had very few family
connections and started working in
grocery stores and ultimately managing
them and then owning a few and were able
to send their kids to college I was
raised as a conservative Jew we were not
particularly religious but we were at
least twice a year religious and but as
very much raised and the kind of soil of
Jewish stories and Jewish values which
have surfaced in my life in a lot of
unexpected ways particularly through
writing when I would have least expected
it frankly and I presently live in
Brooklyn like everybody else
wears glasses can I tell you I mean why
can't tell me a little bit how you got
into fiction writing how did you get
into writing so in certain ways you know
there's two kinds of writers it seems to
me those who always wanted to be writers
and who kept Diaries when they were
young and would read books under the
covers after they were told to go to bed
and writers like me who came to it much
later
in life and sort of through the backdoor
and often through the process of
eliminating everything else that they
might possibly be you know I didn't want
to be a doctor I didn't want to be a
lawyer and so on and so forth I am NOT a
great lover of books actually and it
might be surprising to you or some of
your viewers to hear that I'm not a huge
reader of books but I do love and value
what books can do and especially what
they can do for me in my own life which
is organizing chaotic thoughts and
feelings giving me a context to engage
with my own thoughts and feelings the
poet WH Auden said I look at what I
write so that I can see what I think and
that's been my experience with novels
and it's been my experience with
nonfiction I've never started a book
with clear ideas I've never started a
book with arguments to make or
characters that I wanted to delineate or
a plot that I wanted to unspool I
usually start books with a few very weak
instincts and in the process of sitting
with myself in a room over time and
devoting myself my energy and that time
to just looking inside and figuring out
what it is that's going on inside and
figuring it out through the process of
organizing it I've come to get some
reflections of Who I am that I'm very
grateful for and it's why I would
encourage everybody to write you know
the world doesn't necessarily need more
novels the world doesn't necessarily
need more nonfiction but it doesn't need
more people who are figuring out what
they think and feel
I assume it's how you think about your
own show as well like this room is a
kind of context to figure out what what
one thinks it's exactly read to me
before I before I talk about
particularly issues very often I have to
organize my thoughts and a piece of
writing and then I sort of know exactly
how I want to structure the show or how
I want to structure my own thoughts
about any particular subject I do have
one more question for you and we're
gonna get to that in just one second but
first you need to go and subscribe
over at Daley wire.com if you want to
hear Jonathan Safran Foer's answer you
have to be a subscriber to subscribe
head on over to Daley where com click
subscribe you can hear the end of our
conversation
there well Jonathan thank you so much
for stopping by it really is a pleasure
to have somebody on who is not from our
sort of typical walk of life the book is
we are the weather it's available
September 17th you can pre-order it
right now really thank you for your time
and crucially the Ben Shapiro shows
Sunday special is directed by Mathis
Glover and produced by Jonathan hey
executive producer Jeremy Boren
associate producer Colton Haws our
guests are booked by Kaitlyn Manor
post-production is supervised by Alex
Singaram editing by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Camino hair and makeup
is by Joshua alvera title graphics by
Cynthia Angulo the Ben Shapiro show
Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
[Music]